So, now that we have our test specifications. Test specification number one that
says that a plus b must be greater than zero. And test specification
number two, for which a plus b must be less than zero. I'd
like to do another small quiz and ask you to write some test
cases that will implement these specifications. And I want you to write the
test cases in this format. I want you to specify for each one
of the test cases, what is the value of a that you need
to use. What is the value of b that you need to use.
And since a test case, I like to remind you, is
not just a set of inputs. But is the set of
inputs plus expected output? I also want you to specify, what
is the expected output for these test cases? And in particular,
since we have two characteristics of the output, one is the
color of the output and the other one is the actual
value. I want you to specify for each test case, what
is the expected output color and what is the expected value?